[музика]
Доброго дня і Ласкаво просимо до
програми У фокусі Європа минув рік а
відтоді як Росія розпочала
повномасштабне вторгнення в Україну рік
тому Багато хто вважав що величезна
російська армія легко візьме країну під
свій контроль впевненою виглядала і сама
Росія
однак наступ швидко зупинився Україна
вела за пеклі бої але війна з постошила
країну російська армія завдає ударів по
енергетиці України і від цього потерпає
в першу чергу цивільне населення люди
продовжують страждати від російської
агресії
незадовго до початку війни ми
познайомилися у Києві з Мартою лікаркою
вона та її чоловік Сергій хотіли
протистояти загрозі з боку Росії тому
незважаючи на відсутність бойового
досвіду вони вирішили стати волонтерами
та допомагати армії тепер після року
перебування на фронті вони кажуть що
Війна змінила їх так само як і всю
країну
Марта та Сергій у відпустці з фронту уже
кілька місяців вони не мали часу
прогулятися Києвом разом вони на службі
з першого дня війни
[музика]
цього разу я нібито повернулася повністю
в довоєнний час я бачив всі зміни що
відбуваються з Києвом і мені здається що
через кілька місяців після початку війни
Київ ніби оновився і зараз Тут набагато
спокійніше Я б сказала
так і це добре добре мати місце куди ти
можеш повернутися з лінії фронту і
зрозуміти що Тут все спокійно
ми вперше зустрілися з цією парою за
кілька тижнів до повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії Марта та Сергій тоді
тільки-но вступили до лавсел
територіальної оборони України
військового резерву збройних сил України
мало хто з них мав попередній військовий
досвід Марта та Сергій теж його не мали
вони тренувалися раз на тиждень
починаючи з базових навичок ведення бою
друга
вихід на коліно Браво
усе це що ви могли бачити в кіно в
документальних фільмах здається дуже
простим але насправді коли ти починаєш
це робити Це доволі складно тому що
треба знати як це робити правильно щоб
не наражати на небезпеку себе і своїх
колег Тому це дуже важливі навички дуже
базові але дуже важливі навички
перекласти
[музика]
на той час сили територіальної оборони
мали підтримати військових у випадку
війни Але переважно за лінією фронту на
блокпостах наприклад
рік тому Ніхто не знав чи буде
вторгнення Росії але якщо війна такі
прийде Марта знала що хоче бути готовою
до неї
іноземцям Важко пояснити чому ми точно
знаємо чого очікувати від Росії але в
нашій історії це траплялося
багато-багато разів коли вони просто
фізично знищували все коріння українців
Марта не вважала себе авантюристкою до
війни вона жила звичайним спокійним
життям
у неї був будинок під Києвом Сад і
домашні тварини після отримання медичної
освіти Марта керувала дослідженнями для
міжнародних фармацевтичних компаній не
виходячи з дому але вона відчувала що
спокій не триватиме довго
майже Неможливо уявити що станеться якщо
мені доведеться покинути все це якщо
мені доведеться просто боротися але все
буде зруйновано таке може статися
я намагаюся бути готовою до цього тому
що все-таки як би це сказати однозначно
Я не хочу зберегти це ціною життя в
окупації
[музика]
це було близько
війна прийшла набагато швидше ніж
очікувалося спочатку війни пара стала
частиною сил оборони коли російські
війська стрімко наступали на Київ їхнє
рідне місто стало зоною бойових дій
Сергій воював В окопах А Марта служила
Медиком у медпункті
[музика]
сьогодні сили територіальної оборони вже
не залишаються далеко за лінією фронту
вони стали активними бойовими
підрозділами і перебувають на
найнебезпечніших ділянках фронту
[музика]
Марта та Сергій нещодавно побували на
запеклому фронті у Донбасі
[сміх]
[музика]
Я все ще боюся всього бо Сергій трошки
тобто не трошки він набагато більш
досвідчений у цьому А я все ще боюся але
коли все сталося так що я мушу туди
їхати то знаєте я просто поїхала інакше
я б не поїхала туди ніколи
[музика]
зараз вперше подружжя має трохи часу для
відпочинку разом
Чесно кажучи у перші місяці війни Я не
був налаштований дуже оптимістично у
мене було відчуття що ми щохвилини
програємо це була велика проблема
Важко було бачити це з новин з ситуації
що складалися
але я бачу як армії стали сильнішою і я
дуже з цим пишаюся
але коли Вони гуляють рідним містом які
зараз більш-менш Мирне вони натрапляють
на нагадування про війну
у центрі Києва Влада влаштувала виставку
розбитих російських танків
але ці двоє вже бачили багато таких
гіпотетична ситуація до якої Вони
готувалися більше року тому стала
смертоносною і надто гіркою реальністю
[музика]
люди в Естонії також стурбовані
російським нападом Ця балтійська країна
підтримує позицію заходу проти Путіна
Естонія Член ЄС і НАТО західний
військовий Альянс намагається зменшити
побоювання Естонії на авіабазі емарі із
2014 року звідси злітають винищувачі
НАТО для захисту повітряного простору
над балтикою німецький Пілот Крістоф
гахмайстер розповідає Що у випадку
надзвичайних ситуацій кожна секунда
важлива
термобілизна гідрокостюм черевики
комбінезон Рятувальний жилет і шолом
підполковнику крістофу гахмайстер у
потрібну менше двох хвилин щоб все це
одягнути
поруч чекай його єврофайтер заправлений
із споряджений
якщо по лунає сигнал тривоги Пілот
повинен бути у повітрі менш ніж за 15
хвилин
це дуже короткий проміжок часу для такої
накладної системи
не секрет що всіх пілотів коли вони
міцно сплять і лунає сигнал тривоги
Пусть трохи підвищується
Адреналін піднімається тому що ви
намагаєтесь зібратися і бути в повній
готовності щоб виконати свою роботу
незалежно від того день це чи ніч
Гах майстер командир німецького загону у
складі посиленої місії НАТО з
патрулювання повітряного простору
Естонії під його командуванням чотири
винищувачі єврофайтер їхні пілоти
наземний Екіпаж і допоміжний персонал
загалом близько 150 осіб
їхні завдання захищати повітряний
простір над країнами Балтії виявляти
потенційно ворожі літаки і не дозволяти
їм заходити у повітряний простір НАТО
[музика]
винищувачі НАТО регулярно можна почути
над сусіднім містом кейла за 10 км від
аеропорту
і не Всі в захваті від присутності НАТО
в регіоні
вони скрізь фашисти
А хто фашисти НАТО
чомусь коли це російські війська то все
Караул окупація
літають і начався нормально
звісно подобається
бо я знаю навіщо вони тут літають мені
так буде спокійніше
вони щоб захистити нас у випадку
потенційної атаки на мою думку це все
фігня все це ми ніколи не знаємо що
Росія захоче зробити далі
щоб забезпечити постійну готовність
літаків до польотів механіки працюють
цілодобово
тисячі деталей і понад 40 комп'ютерів
необхідно перевіряти і обслуговувати на
кожну годину в повітрі йде кілька годин
роботи на землі кожна година польоту
коштує близько 74 тисяч євро крім того
озброєння літака надзвичайно дороге
інша червона ракета
і це маркування вказує на те що вона
бойова Вона має внутрішній ракетний
двигун який запалюється і відправляє
ракету з цієї направляючі Прямо в ціль
жодна з трьох балтійських країн Естонія
Латвія чи Литва немає власних
винищувачів для патрулювання повітряного
простору з моменту вступу до НАТО у 2004
році цю роль взяли на себе союзники а
після незаконної анексії Криму Росією у
2014 році НАТО здійснює вильоти з другої
бази в емарі
ви можете побачити присутність країн
НАТО і не лише в Балтійському регіоні
вони присутні в Польщі та Румунії аж до
Чорного моря присутність НАТО також
стала більш помітною для російських
військ
і ми напоготові
російські літаки недалеко
один із їхніх головних маршрутів
проходить на північ від естонського
узбережжя
російські військові літаки регулярно
літають без транспондерів пристроїв які
передають інформацію та дані про політ
вони не зв'язуються з авіадиспетчерами
на землі що становить потенційну
небезпеку для цивільних літаків
у таких випадках на перехоплення та
ідентифікацію літака висилаються пілоти
ВПС Німеччини
коли два винищувачі зближуються в
міжнародному повітряному просторі без
узгодження це завжди небезпечно
Коли ви наближаєтесь до літака з яким У
вас немає контакту і ви не знаєте що
робить інший Пілот який Його наміри чи
траєкторія польоту звісно ви трохи
напруження
крістом гак майстер каже що його війська
довго і наполегливо тренувалася щоб бути
готовими до будь-якого можливого
сценарію для німців ця місія завершиться
у квітні коли їх замінять британські
королівські військово-повітряні сили
Туреччину та Сирію знову сколихнули
землетруси знову є загиблі поранені і
багато страждань турецька Влада
зареєструвала понад 6 тисяч підземних
поштовхів після катастрофи що сталася
кілька тижнів тому
густо населені райони мають набагато
більший ризик експерти попереджають що
великі міста такі як Стамбул можуть
повністю зруйнуватися оскільки там часто
не дотримуються будівельних норм у місті
дюща деякі колишні жертви землетрусу
зуміли побудувати собі сейсмостійкі
будинки
цей новий житловий район взагалі не мав
бути збудований тут він розташований у
Західному турецькому місті дюще одному з
найбільш сейсманебезпечних регіонів
Туреччини
ербай юджак не вважає це проблемою
разом із відповідальним будівельним
інженером ujack обговорює останні деталі
будівельних робіт разом Вони контролюють
кожен крок процесу
деякі будівельні компанії додають
хімікати бетон що він краще Розтікався
якщо ви самі не будете стежити за цим на
будівельному майданчику То можете
потрапити в ситуацію подібну до
землетрусу на сході чим більше нагляду
тим безпечніше
понад два десятиліття тому юрист южак
разом із однодумцями заснував проект
кооперативного житлового будівництва
хоуп-хоус дім Надії Вони хотіли створити
спільноту і побудувати доступне та
сейсмостійке житло
тоді їхній рідне місто дюсще тільки-но
пережило один із найсильніших
землетрусів за всю свою історію його
сила становила 7 балів за шкалою ріхтера
загинуло понад 800 людей
на гігант парлак вижила але оскільки
вона орендувала житло то після
землетрусу опинилася на вулиці вона
приєдналася до хоуп-хопс і тепер майже
24 роки потому вона показує ербалію чаку
квартиру у яку щойно переїхала це одна з
237 квартир
це Кухня
Я хочу поглянути
звісно ми все що боїмося що будуть
землетруси але ми точно знаємо що наші
будинки не зруйнуються як ті що на сході
ми всі регулярно відвідували будівельний
майданчик радіючи кожному Кроку вперед
встановленню вікон чи прокладання
газових труб ми тут як одна велика
родина
вони терплячі чекали всі ці роки і
довіряли нашим прогнозам
Без довіри майбутніх мешканців ми б не
мали такого успіху
їхній успіх став прикладом для
наслідування у Туреччині свого часу
кооперативу довелося судитися з державою
щоб отримати земельну ділянку для
постраждалих від землетрусу зрештою суд
виніс рішення на їхню користь
згідно закону Ми також мали право на
пільговий кредит на будівництво від
держави але спочатку нам його і не
хотіли давати
зрештою ми подали на них до суду і
виграли справу
за кілька кілометрів звідси мертю ще
перевіряє доставку допомоги для регіону
на сході Туреччини які постраждав від
нещодавнього землетрусу його місто хоче
відправити туди мобільні туалети та
душові кабіни фарук осьлю переконаний що
його місто добре підготоване щоб
витримати наступний великий землетрус у
дюсченовій будівлі не можуть бути вищому
за чотири поверхи що незвичною для
Туреччини
ми завершуємо проєкт оновлення міста
залишилося близько 25% старого
небезпечного фонду і ми хочемо замінити
його найближчим часом
правлячої партії справедливості та
розвитку Але він дуже схвально
відгукується про рішучість будівельного
кооперативу У своєму місці
вони змогли об'єднатися і довести цей
житловий комплекс до кінця
Я вважаю що це великий успіх
в останнє земля здригалася у дюсче У
листопаді минулого року але незважаючи
на землетрус силою 5 балів за школою
ріхтера все пройшло відносно спокійно
більшість травм не були надто серйозними
хоча пошкоджені будівлі були дому Надії
серед них не було будинки витримали
землетрус і залишились неушкодженими
я не дуже хвилювалася за будівлі але ми
все одно помчали на будівельний
майданчик щоб подивитися Я вже встигла
поставити деякі меблі в квартирі але
жодна річ навіть не впала
для ючака парлака та інших членів
будівельного кооперативу боротьба що
тривали десятиліттями добігає кінця їхня
боротьба за сестмостійке доступне житло
увінчалося успіхом і вони сподіваються
що це може стати натхненням для інших у
ціни спокійні часи
Вони живуть у жахливих умовах і працюють
за дуже малі гроші на півдні Італії
тисячі африканських робітників які
збирають врожай змушені жити в
антисанітарних притулках у цих
помешканнях часто відсутнє елементарною
опалення проекти допомоги в Сан
фердинанду прагне відновити гідність
людей побудувавши для них спеціальне
житло ініціатива сподівається полегшити
їхні труднощі
самих їде на роботу
а він попросив залишитися анонімним щоб
захистити свою сім'ю Санок живе в
розарно невеликому містечку в Калабрії
але він родом із гвіней чоловік живе в
Італії вже 8 років і зараз працює
збирачем апельсинів
ми супроводжуємо сануха на рівнину джоя
тауро
тут працює багато робітників що і як
Санок приїхали сюди як мігранти з Африки
ми починаємо о 7:30 ранку і працюємо у
полі сім годин
його зарплата становить від 50 до 60
євро на день Це хороша робота за хороші
гроші каже він але вона скоро
закінчиться
коли Бог каже що збір врожаю закінчився
нам треба шукати іншу роботу
ми йдемо туди де є робота
Санок показує на місце де він жив
донедавна табір для робітників що
збирають врожай поблизу джоя тауро
близько 500 людей живуть там у
небезпечних умовах нам радять залишатися
зовні оскільки табір частково затоплений
ситуація складна
зараз також немає місця для ночівлі
[музика]
кажу що скоро буде нове житло де буде
більше місця поїсти тут або спробувати
щось приготувати важко
Я вмію готувати але вода зі скважини
непридатна для пиття якщо її пити то
можна захворіти
сміття приваблює щурі ви бродячих собак
Вода від нічного дощу накопичується між
наметами ми відвідуємо будинок гідності
тут знайшли безпечний прихисток близько
20 трудових мігрантів
Чому він називається дім гідності
дім гідності тому що для нас важливо що
це не пасивна форма допомоги
працівники беруть участь у витратах
відповідно до своїх доходів 90 євро це
максимум це не безкоштовно житло і ми
вважаємо що це важливо для того щоб
прибрати елемент пасивності
Санок ділить квартиру з чотирма іншими
чоловіками тут одна ванна кімната і дві
спальні
Це моя кімната і моє ліжко з теплою
ковдрою інакше я б замерз
я купив у місті за 40 євро
Франческо допоміг санаху отримати дозвіл
на проживання та роботу без цього
працівники які збирають врожай фактично
не мають жодних прав
ми своєрідний безпечний простір і цей
будинок тому приклад
середземноморська Надія працює над тим
щоб забезпечити гуманітарні способи
дістатися сюди а потім ми надаємо захист
після того як люди приїжджають
Франческо також отримує допомогу від
місцевих фермерів кооператив маніятера
купує апельсини за справедливими цінами
та умовами
потім фрукти надсилають церковним
громадам та приватним особам на прикладі
Німеччини
виручені кошти йдуть на підтримку
ініціатив для мігрантів у Калабрії
одна з характерних рис традиційних
ланцюгів постачання в нашому сільському
господарстві жорстока експлуатація
людини людиною
найбільше від цього страждають робітники
які збирають врожай з країн що не
входять до Європейського Союзу наприклад
трудові мігранти з Африки які живуть у
немислимих умовах
організації з надання допомоги та
виробники апельсинів працювали разом Щоб
дати сезонним робітникам надію замах має
дах над головою Коли повертається додому
і почувається в більшій безпеці ніж
багато інших робітників які збирають
врожай
[музика]
тостер невід'ємна частина більшості
британських будинків на сніданок часто
подають підсмажений білий хліб з маслом
і джемом але що робити коли тостер
перестає працювати багато британців
просто викидають свої прилади але
ремонтна майстерня у Лондоні показує що
є й інший спосіб ремонт як правило
обходиться дешевше і це набагато
екологічніше і цей тренд набирає обертів
Сподіваюся це надихне і вас ремонтувати
свою техніку а на цьому Ми завершуємо
випуску фокусі Європи Дякуємо за
перегляд до зустрічі українською мовою
озвучено центром медіа ініціатив Київ
2023 рік
[музика]